okay so today we're going to continue
our discussion about photosynthesis and
last time i introduced the reactions of
photosynthesis
and pointed out that really what we're
talking about
is oxidation reduction reactions and so
the net reaction of photosynthesis water
plus carbon dioxide goes to carbohydrate
and oxygen
is really the opposite of burning wood
right so if burning wood carbon
oxidation
is favorable reversing this obviously
needs energy
input and that energy input is light
that's
coming from the sun and we started
to discuss a bit about how this reaction
works and
i mentioned that photosynthesis is
broken down into
light reactions and dark reactions and
so
the light reactions are really
along the same lines of the oxidative
phosphorylation electron transport chain
that we described and that is basically
using energy from the sun to use water
as an electron donor
to generate nadph as well as
oxygen in doing so light from the sun
makes this
this process favorable that favorable
electron transport can then be used
to generate delta psi delta ph which can
create atp
do other work just like oxidative
phosphorylation of course photosynthesis
came
first oxidative phosphorylation came
second even though we taught it in the
reduce or in the reverse order
um and these reactions also produce
nadph
which can be used in the so-called dark
reactions
to synthesize carbohydrates now the dark
reactions again
i mentioned can be done in the light or
the dark
they don't need light they use the nadph
from the light reactions as well as the
atp
produced from the light reactions to
take co2 and turn
it into into carbohydrate and that
allows plants to
store carbon reduced carbon energy
for later such that when the sun is not
shining
they can then use that carbohydrate to
oxidize it
in all of the reactions we've already
learned about and make sure they're able
to generate
atp keep their atp adp ratio high at
night
and then switch back to using
photosynthesis when the sun is out
during the day
now today what we're going to discuss is
both the light and the dark reactions in
great detail
to fill in how those processes happen
so first we're going to start with the
light reactions
and so the light reactions if it's like
oxidative phosphorylation that is we're
going to generate
a membrane potential build a battery
that is to occur
at a membrane and so those membranes
are the cell membrane of a bacteria
or prokaryote
or an intracellular membrane
of a eukaryotic
photosynthetic organism and that
intracellular membrane
is of course the chloroplast that
you learned about in grade school and so
the chloroplast is the photosynthetic
equivalent of the mitochondria
oxidative phosphorylation eukaryotes
happen at a mitochondrial membrane
in photosynthesis and eukaryotes happens
at a
chloroplast membrane and so just to be
explicit about this so if this is
our photosynthetic bacteria some
prokaryotic cell
it will use photosynthesis to make
a delta psi delta ph across
the cell membrane and then it can
utilize that
to provide energy for the organism
very similar to what we said about
oxidative phosphorylation in a bacteria
and you can imagine that then there was
some early eukaryotic cell
that ended up engulfing this
photosynthetic prokaryote and in the
process
the atp generated could be exchanged
for adp across those membranes and in
the end this is how one ends up with
this
double membrane organelle
within
the engulfed prokaryotic species
with having uh the membrane potential
built across
this having the membrane potential built
across this inner
mitochondrial membrane or
inner membrane of in this case the
chloroplast
and so if you remember we drew the
mitochondria as having this double
membrane structure
the inner mitochondrial membrane where
oxadophosphorylation happened
protons were pumped into this inner
membrane space okay
and chloroplasts have basically
the same structure but it's a little bit
more complicated at least on the surface
and that's because
chloroplasts have evolved this further
to have what essentially are extreme
christie those folds of the mitochondria
called christie
these sort of extreme folds is basically
what happens in a chloroplast
so if we draw here a giant chloroplast
so this here would be the outer membrane
of the chloroplast
so the chloroplast also has an inner
membrane
all right so this here is then the inner
membrane of the chloroplast
you can imagine that if you had
sort of this extreme folding in
of the christie but actually pinched off
this little piece of membrane here
you would now end up with stacks
of membrane within the
chloroplast okay so you still here have
this
inner membrane here that goes all the
way around but now you have
these little membrane stacks that now
exist within the chloroplast
this here is called grana
and this inside of these stacks
what is called the lumen
is really the equivalent of the
inter-membrane space
of the mitochondria so the inside of
this
is basically equivalent to the inner
membrane space
of the mitochondria such that if i draw
one of these pinched off pieces of
membrane in
gigantic form you're basically pumping
protons into the lumen
into this inter membrane space
equivalent
and so you can imagine that you have
this electron transport chain
set up where electrons are transferred
from water to nadp
plus making oxygen and nadph
that is electron transport is made
favorable by light that generates a
membrane potential across
this membrane um
which is by the way this membrane
which is same there this is called the
thylakoid
membrane
okay thylakoid t-h-y-l-a-k-o-i-d
membrane so you build a potential across
this thylakoid membrane and then that
potential
can be used to synthesize
atp
within this other space
this wider space here which is called
the stroma
which is the equivalent of the matrix
of the mitochondria and so
basically the chloroplast is set up in a
very similar way to the mitochondria
but because it makes these membrane
stacks
it looks like it's a little bit
different but it's really pumping
protons into the inter membrane space
which would happen in the mitochondria
an equivalent space which is
the lumen of these stacks is what
happens within a chloroplast
that charge on the membrane that delta
psi delta ph
can then be used to do work like
synthesizing atp
that happens in rather than then
and that happens in the in the stroma of
the
or the matrix equivalent the stroma of
the chloroplast
and so effectively you have nadph and
atp produced in the stroma
and so it turns out the dark
reactions when we talk about them later
will occur here in the stroma of the
chloroplast
and the light reactions of course are
happening
over here at the
thylakoid membrane
okay now this is actually a
cool innovation that nature has come up
with for this and because
by making these extreme christy you can
imagine that there's a very small space
here that you're pumping protons into
that means that fewer protons pump will
be allow you to generate
a higher potential a higher gradient of
of of protons delta
ph and so that means that
that then can be used to drive energy in
a more
efficient way than you might get using
this
much larger inter membrane
space okay and so
light reactions here at the thylakoid
membrane within the chloroplast
dark reactions here in the stroma of the
chloroplast
all right so that's the anatomy
all right now let's get back to what's
actually happening here
in these light reactions so of course
the trick
of the light reactions is to come up
with some way to make
water a good electron donor such that
you can have favorable
electron trans transfer to nadph
which is of course what's necessary to
have
energy released to generate delta psi
delta ph
and so of course to do this we still
have to follow all the same
thermodynamic rules that existed
before that we talked about for
oxidative phosphorylation
so you should remember from those
lectures that electron transfer is going
to be favorable
if we move from a lower to a higher
standard
reduction potential all right so if we
just draw this out so here's
a physiological range of standard
reduction potentials from
one point negative 1.6 to
positive 0.8 volts okay so this here
would be
a range of standard um reduction
potentials
so remember a change in standard product
reduction potential that's positive
that means moving this direction down
as i've drawn this axis from smaller
to larger i realize i drew it upside
down than the way
you probably are normally used to
looking at this but basically if you go
from a more negative to a positive
number or a more negative to a less
negative or a positive to a more
positive
basically a change in this direction
which is going to have a
positive change in standard production
potential is going to end up having a
negative change in delta g not prime
and so that means equilibrium is going
to favor electron transport
moving down in this direction so now
let's just
give this some real numbers so
the standard reduction potential of
oxygen water
sits down here it's 0.86
you have to worry about exact numbers
okay
the standard reduction potential of
nad
h or nadp h they're the same the
nicotinamide group
is here it's about negative um 0.32
all right and this is why oxidative
phosphorylation is works is because
there is a net positive change in
standard reduction potential that is you
go from a lower to a higher standard
reduction potential
if we do electron transport in the tcas
in the oxidative phosphorylation that
means energy is released as we transfer
electrons from nadh
to oxygen all right so
that is favorable that favorable energy
release
is what can be coupled to proton pumping
to generate delta psi delta ph
and allow the cell to do other work all
right now
you cannot
change the properties of water just
because
you add light to it all right so it
still sits at the standard reduction
potential
but what happens in photosynthesis is
basically you use
light to excite
an electron that effectively
moves water up here to a more negative
electron up here to generate an electron
that's up here at a more negative
standard reduction potential than nadph
which of course now moving down becomes
favorable okay and so here now you're
going from
more negative to here and then from
there to there
each of those is favorable this means
you can use
this favorable electron transfer the
energy release from
the favorable movement of electrons from
this excited electron to
nadph generate nadph
then you can also use donate those to
the electron transport chain and ox phos
with oxygen with water with oxygen as a
final electron acceptor
to net generate delta psi delta ph and
ox phos
and so this works to generate it in
photosynthesis
and this works to generate it in
oxidative phosphorylation
and we've not violated any laws of
thermodynamics and we're able to
in both cases create this membrane
potential build this battery
that now allows you to do work
such as synthesize atp keep the atp adp
ratio high
allow the cell to do all the unfavorable
reactions that it needs to do
all right so now let's talk a bit
about this process so of course this
happens with
visible light but i want to start with
sort of asking
a fundamental question why do we use
visible light
or put another way what is visible light
anyway well visible light is of course
just electromagnetic radiation a photon
on the electromagnetic radiation
spectrum
and visible light is defined by what we
see okay so
if we draw this out okay this is
hopefully something that you've covered
in a physics class somewhere
along the way so if this here
is the
electro magnetic spectrum is drawn out
so down here you have your short
wavelength electromagnetic radiation
down here you have your long
wavelength things okay
so higher energy lower energy
okay on this end x-ray uv light then you
get to the
visible spectrum and we go from the
purple light
down to the red light
okay and eventually we get into the
infrared light and ultimately
down to microwaves and basically
shorter wavelength and longer length
wavelengths more energy
less energy and so just to give you
some numbers so this here is on the
order
of 300 kilojoules this is on the order
of 170 kilojoules
and so adp to atp
conversion so we before i talked about
in kcal's per mole but it's on the order
of 30
kilojoules for that and so
this part of the electromagnetic
spectrum
is the right order of magnitude it turns
out
to transduce energy in a realm
that matches the energy required or
released
from the atp to adp conversion reaction
all right you also know from just
popular use right you go out in the sun
when it's a nice day
you put sunscreen on why do you do that
that's because the uv
light that's filtered through our
atmosphere from the sun
can cause sunburns that is it can cause
damage to
our skin to other biological molecules
obviously x-rays
you go get an x-ray done you get covered
with lead in all the places they don't
want to
have the x-ray done why because x-rays
can
cause uh damage we use those to treat
cancer
okay and so things down on this end
too much energy damages biological
molecules all right this is the sweet
spot
where you don't get a lot of damage to
the biological molecules
and the energy is right to synthesize um
um to transduce energy
on a magnitude that works for biological
systems
come down to this end well now you get
to be too little energy right you get
down to the
infrared and the microwaves okay this is
like your tv remote control this is
you know the cell phones that if you
were in class as opposed to listening to
this online you would be checking
instead of listening to me
so this direction too little energy
is transduced to actually matter for the
biological systems and so
that's really why this spectrum of light
is what's involved in photosynthesis
however
i also want to remind you that visible
light is a human construct it's what we
as humans can see
and photosynthesis evolved long before
humans
all right we needed photosynthesis first
before any animal life
can evolve and so this visible light
designation
is completely arbitrary all right and in
fact
we evolved from photosynthetic organisms
and so it's really photosynthetic
pigments that involved first
to capture light in this range that we
then repurposed
in order to see so in essence
photosynthesis
defines the visual spectrum because
what we see is defined by the pigments
that came because it evolved from
photosynthesis the
carotenoids the carrot the why do we
carrots that are good for our eyes they
have
the pigments in carrots carotenoids
which we'll draw in a little bit
that are ultimately related to our
visual pigments
and we didn't invent those
photosynthetic organisms invented those
to work in this spectrum to harvest
light from the sun for energy and we
repurpose those molecules
as a way for us to see all right
so how does this work well
again i got to remind you of a little
bit more physics a little quantum
physics this is not uh obviously we're
not going to go into this at the level
you get in a physics class and hopefully
you've seen this before
but remember if you think back to
physics and physical chemistry
that electrons sit in discrete orbitals
within molecules okay so we can draw
those orbitals like this and so you'd
have some
you know electron pair sitting there in
some
orbital in a molecule and if you
deliver light with the
right amount of energy the white quanta
of energy
you can now excite one of those
electrons
up here into a orbital with a
higher energy and of course
that's not stable so it will decay
and when that electron decays back to
[Music]
the ground state this then re-releases
a another photon of light at a
longer wavelength okay so longer
wavelength light is emitted and that's
effectively
fluorescence right so you excite
something electron bounces up into a
higher orbital
it decays releases the some of the
energy that it absorbed as it
transitions back that is fluorescence
this happens very very fast
and basically what photosynthesis does
is it takes advantage
of this excited state and it effectively
transfers that
electron away creating a charge
separation prior to that
electron decaying back into the ground
state
orbital this occurs very fast and so
photosynthesis has to occur
very very fast in order to make this
work
and in essence this is sort of the way
that photosynthesis is able to capture
energy and connect it to a biological
system that allows us to build an
electron transport chain
and so in essence photosynthesis the way
the energy is absorbed
is it's what you learned in physics the
right quanta of light
causes an electron to excite into a
higher energy orbital
and then that electron is transferred
away creating a charge separation
before that energy of that excited
electron can decay is fluorescence
that creates a charge separation and
that charge separation
now has an electron such that that
electron can now be favorably
transferred
to nadph that energy
released in that favorable transfer can
be coupled to make delta psi delta ph
and then that transduces energy in
exactly the same way
we learned about for oxidative
phosphorylation
all right so to do this
what do we need when we need a pigment
that can absorb
a photon of the right wavelength or
put another way of the right energy and
then
quickly transfer that electron
away and so you need two things you need
light acceptors that can
absorb energy of the right energy the
right wavelength of light
and redox carriers to transfer those
electrons away
so what are the light acceptors well
these are basically pigments that can
absorb
visible light and redox carriers are
electron carriers which we've been
talking about now for
several lectures so let's start with the
light acceptor so this is something
that's tuned to the right energy the
right wavelength
and so this is chlorophyll
so we all know plants contain
chlorophyll that's important for
photosynthesis well what is chlorophyll
well it's a conjugated
pyrrole very similar to heme except
remember heme had iron
in it saw it for hemoglobin saw it again
in the electron transport chain
and i'm going to show you chlorophyll
chlorophyll is going to look a lot like
that except it has a magnesium
conjugated to the tetra pyrrole
rather than iron and so
okay so here you have a tetra parole
with a magnesium in the middle
conjugated double bond system all the
way around
makes sense that should absorb visible
light
all those conjugated double bonds
there's some
r group decorations hanging off over
here
chlorophyll also has this additional
decoration over here
including a long lipid tail here to make
this
will sit within a membrane
apologies i missed through that
lipid tail hangs off down there but this
here is effectively
what the structure of chlorophyll looks
like
with this r and r prime
being specific groups you can look up if
you're interested but basically
these are the decorations that
define what are referred to as a type
and b type chlorophylls
remember we had a b and c type
cytochromes that were basically
similar molecules with slightly
different decorations on them
the types defined slightly by the
absorbance properties of these pigments
but effectively what's key about
chlorophyll is that it's this conjugated
double bond system in the
tetraparole that ultimately allows it to
absorb
visible light now chlorophyll is of
course the most famous pigment but it's
not the only pigment that photosynthetic
organisms used
so they also use other pigments to
absorb
visible light and so there's a class of
pigments that look very similar to
chlorophyll
you can look up the structures if you
want they're called
phytobillins they're also tetraparoles
very similar to chlorophyll except for
instance pheophytin
does not contain any magnesium or other
thing conjugated in the center okay so
no
magnesium otherwise looks similar to
chlorophyll
and then there's other ones there's so
called
phycoerythrin
which you might guess is
red so that's a red pigment
there's
phycocyanin which is you might guess
is a
blue pigment and then maybe the most
famous one that you've know about that's
not
chlorophyll are the so-called
carotenoids
this includes things like beta-carotene
okay i think we all know that
beta-carotene
is orange
okay what does beta-carotene look like
i'll
draw it out for you
there's beta carotene another long
conjugated
double bond system obviously you don't
need to memorize the structures of
any of these you can always look up
structures of these pigments
the point is is that nature has a
variety
of these structures all with conjugated
double bond systems
all will tuned to absorb visible light
and this of course also then becomes
a major pigment for our visual system
repurposed from the plant using it for
chlorosynthesis
for for photosynthesis and why have all
these pigments well
the idea is because if we say here
what's the absorbance then
across the electromagnetic spectrum
with the purple the short wavelength
being down here
and the red the long wavelength being on
this end
well now effectively you have
chlorophylls
that cover that spectrum and so
they'll have you know
some peak here for say
a type chlorophylls and then you'll have
some other
peak for b
type chlorophylls okay these are always
approximate and so that's basically the
a
and b type chlorophylls wire plants
green because they absorb
in two peaks on either end and so that
reflects the green light
in the middle all right but now you have
these other pigments that will fill in
the middle and so
the beta carotene the orange beta
carotene will allow you
to
plants will have an absorption spectrum
that will peak somewhere
in that range and then you'll have the
phycorythrins within a
zorch absorption spectrum that will peak
somewhere
in that range and then the phycocyanins
with an absorption spectrum that will
peak somewhere in that range
and basically by covering all of these
different pigments
plants and other photosynthetic
organisms can now
adapt to different light niches within
the
within the natural world really
capturing the full spectrum
of visible light and the nice thing is
this also leads to all the
beautiful colors and whatnot that exists
across
photosynthetic organisms different
plants algaes and bacteria
all different colors and basically we'll
use these different pigments to
ultimately
cover this visual spectrum this right
spectrum with the right amount of energy
to carry out the processes that's
necessary
to run the light reactions of
photosynthesis
okay now even though there's this
variety of pigments
effectively all photosynthetic organisms
as far as we know work in a very similar
way and that
they basically arrange these pigments
always at a membrane always here at this
thylakoid membrane in the chloroplast or
i guess it would be the uh the cell
membrane of a prokaryote
and these are organized into a structure
called the
light harvesting complex
and basically what a light harvesting
complex is
is its pigments arranged in a structure
that basically can channel energy from
the photons captured
down into a place called the
reaction center
okay so you can imagine that you'd have
all kinds of
pigments arranged in a way that
basically will absorb photons
release photons as fluorescents
ultimately going down
to this reaction center and it's in the
reaction center
that really the magic of photosynthesis
happens so what happens at the reaction
center
is pretty well understood from the
structure
of the photosynthetic reaction center
that was
solved about 30 years ago
from in the purple photosynthetic
bacteria and this is very illustrative
for how it works
and so if you look here at the slide
this here is basically a graphical
representation of what that reaction
center
looks like and so effectively
you have a bunch of in this particular
case molecules
up here but really the reaction center
is what exists
down here and in there there's a pair
of chlorophylls we'll talk about in a
second those are there shown graphically
over here
and they will effectively transfer
electrons
around in this direction
to these quinones further away from
the special pair of chlorophylls so
electrons will be transferred from the
chlorophyll after it's excited
down to these quinones creating a charge
separation
that ultimately is going to allow you to
then have a high energy electron that
can be built into an electron transport
chain
and so let's draw that graphically out
over here and so here if we have our
special pair of chlorophylls okay so
chlorophyll if you look at it here is a
relatively a pyrrole lychem it's a flat
molecule
and so these will stack on top of each
other so if they're stacked on top of
each other
and this is looking at them head on you
have this
special pair of chlorophylls you'll
eventually
absorb a photon of light and that will
create
a charge separation
across between that special pair of
chlorophylls that electron before it can
decay
as fluorescence as would normally happen
it's very rapidly transferred out
to a pheophytin
molecule and then it's very rapidly
transferred again
to a quinone called
qa all right so just show that again
here on
here so here's our special pair you get
absorb a photon of light charge
separation at the
special pair electron transfer to the
field fighting
and then down to this quinone and that's
a very fast reaction
you can see that it's actually moving
within space that's
roughly the um you know
distance from one side of the membrane
to another so
on an atomic level quite um a long
distance
and so from this quinone it then will be
transferred again to a second quinone
that's a slower step
i want to remind you how electrons are
transferred on quinones
and so we talked about this already and
we talked about electron transport
okay so here is a
so this here would be an oxidized
quinone just like we saw for coenzyme q
ubiquinone all right so this would be
oxidized quinone and photosynthesis
electron
you can pick up electrons one at a time
okay so that will generate
this
semi-quinone remember with the
stabilized free radical
now you can pick up a second electron
okay and that ultimately generates
the reduced the fully reduced
quinone the quinol
okay
so we talked about this with coenzyme q
and oxidative phosphorylation
remember ubiquinone to ubiquinol
similar thing happening in
photosynthesis also a quinone
can pick up electrons go from the
oxidized to the reduced state
and if you remember in oxidative
phosphorylation
you could then as you transfer the
electrons across
from the oxidized and reduced state of
the quinones you'll pick up
a proton if you pick up those protons
and release those
protons as you transfer electrons on
different sides of the membrane
that can be coupled to pump protons
across the membrane
as you transfer electrons across the
system
exactly what happens here in
photosynthesis
except now that electron is basically
coming from
transfer of an excited electron from the
special pair to the field fighting
ultimately to the quinones
and then from the quinones can now be
transferred down
an electron transport chain
to show this in kind of a quantum
way if you will so if this here
is the
special pair of
chlorophyll and we draw here
the pair of electrons in the special
pair
in the ground state if you get
a photon of light of the right energy
you excite one of those
electrons here into a higher orbital
before that can decay if we transfer
that electron out basically take that
electron
and transfer it out and instead here
give it to the
theophytin
okay so the there's some
orbital in the field fighting it comes
it picks up
this electron that's transferred away
from the
special pair
well now what you have is you basically
have a
negative charge here and a
positive charge up on the special pair
so you've created this
charge separation that electron can then
be further transferred down
the electron transport chain to the
quinones
that then transfer them across the
canola quinones we're pumping
proton okay and ultimately down an
electron transport chain
ultimately with the final electron
acceptor being nadp
plus to make nad
ph okay and you're still left
with this positive charge on the
special pair obviously that's not a very
stable state
so you got to resolve that how can that
be
resolved well lots of things will that's
a
pretty good electron acceptor and so now
even something like water
which is highly abundant can be an
electron donor
and ultimately fixes that
positive charge on the special pair
by taking an electron from water which
of course
generates oxygen this part
of the reaction is carried out by a
complex called the
water splitting complex
we don't have time to get into this
and some manganese um containing enzyme
and it basically controls the
transfer of an electron from water to
oxygen
which hopefully is at least intuitively
you'll see why that's favorable because
you really have this
true positive charge on the special pair
and almost anything
um is a good electron donor to that
including
water all right and so it's really
this charge separation by fast electron
transfer
through the reaction center from the
special chlorophyll pair
ultimately down to quinones that creates
this charge separation
that is ultimately where you can pull an
electron from
water to generate oxygen and if we come
back over here
it's how we made this whole process
work how we made water on a good
electron donor that is we didn't make
the standard
didn't change the standard reduction
potential of
the oxygen water pair instead what we
did is we
basically used light to excite an
electron
in chlorophyll such that
that excited electron now can be
favorably
sits at a low enough standard reduction
potential such that it's favorable to
transfer it to
nadph and then we fix that
charge hole if you will by pulling an
electron from
water and that generates oxygen
all right of course once we're able to
get this favorable electron
transfer now we can couple that to the
pumping of protons
that allows us to make delta psi delta
ph we charge a battery
and that does work um just like
we saw before all right so
why these concepts were so important to
understanding
how energy transduction and biological
systems work
and why i spend so much time talking
about
standard reduction potentials delta psi
delta ph etc
all right now i wanna
describe these concepts and build them
into the context of a chloroplast
electron transport chain
i'm going to show you what happens in
chloroplasts
in higher plants conceptually even
though the details may not be 100 the
same across all photosynthetic organisms
conceptually what i'm going to show you
is exactly the same
regardless of whether it's a
photosynthetic bacteria
or um a chloroplast from a plant
all right so if we draw here this here
being the
thylakoid membrane
okay and so i'm going to draw it such
that this here is the
stroma side of the membrane this is the
lumen side of the membrane remember the
stroma side would be equivalent to the
matrix of the mitochondria where the
lumen side
would be equivalent to the inter
membrane
space of the mitochondria all right so
thylakoid membrane stroma side lumen
side
all right
we have a complex here
this complex is called
photo system 2
abbreviate ps2 all right photo system 2
is going to be linked up
to the water splitting complex which
will
basically pick up an electron
of course injecting light that will
transfer electrons
through effectively what is
a q cycle what we alluded to
happens in oxidative phosphorylation it
didn't have time to describe in great
detail
that can pump protons across the
membrane
those electr as electrons are
transferred into the
next complex which is called
cytochrome bf all right
the next complex cytochrome bf
also can pump
protons across the membrane
those electrons then get transferred
to a soluble protein in the lumen
called plasto
cyanine
from there those electrons now get
transferred
to another complex
called photosystem 1 or
ps1
electrons in
photosystem one can end up
in another complex called
ferradoxin ultimately
transferring those electrons to
nadp plus to generate
nadph and of course that will happen
here on the stromal side of
the membrane because that's where the
dark reactions are going to take place
this has the effect of generating a
delta psi delta ph
across the membrane
and of course that can be used then
that delta psi delta ph
can be used by
a chloroplast f zero
chloroplast f1 atp ace
to generate atp just like we described
from oxidative
phosphorylation okay with the atp also
being generated
on the stromal side of
the membrane so this should look very
similar to what we described for
mitochondrial electron transport so you
see we have
multiple complexes all right including
a cytochrome c-like protein that sits on
the
in this case the lumen side of the
thylakoid membrane plastocyanin
cytochrome c sits in the inner membrane
space of the mitochondria
you transfer electrons including via a
q-quinone-like cycle that pumps protons
have other complexes that pump protons
ultimately
transfer electrons to generate nadph
there's two complexes here that
absorb light photosystem two
and photosystem one
electron transfer i guess classically
would go photosystem two
cytochrome bf plastocyanin photosystem 1
ferridoxin water is the donor
nadph as the acceptor generates delta
psi delta ph
that delta psi delta ph can then be used
to do work
including synthesis of atp as done by
an f-zero f1 atpase just like exists
in the mitochondria of course this
evolved first
and so oxidative phosphorylation looks
like photosynthesis
even though we talked about it oxidative
phosphorylation first and then
photosynthesis
so you will of course looks like
oxidative phosphorylation but of course
remember
it's really not that photosynthesis
looks like oxidative phosphorylation is
that oxidative phosphorylation looks
like
photosynthesis all right now ultimately
the reason this works
is because photosystem ii and
photosystem one
can absorb photons
which ultimately by the processes we
discussed is what makes electron
transfer favorable
from water to nadp plus
to generate oxygen and nadph
all right now i wanna take you through
just to show you how this works because
it
turns out it's also possible to short
circuit this in a way
that can favor more delta psi delta ph
production relative to nadph production
which is important because you can
imagine
that a photosynthetic organism has to
balance its needs
for nadph and atp
both useful molecules but you want to
balance your needs for both of them
and it turns out that this middle part
photosystem one
works with a cytochrome bf in a way that
allows it to
balance that
so
so
okay so if i draw this out
in a little bit more detail
so here's negative 1.6 volts
and here's positive zero point
volts
okay so that's again our standard
reduction potential so remember
water oxygen is going to sit down here
you're going to have in photosystem 1
a special pair called p680
that's the wavelength of
light
at the special pair in
so this here would be photosystem sorry
photosystem
ii that's the special pair within
photosystem 2
absorbs a photon
okay that photon
now becomes an excited electron
that can be transferred away that
ultimately
makes water a good electron donor to
resolve
that charge separation at this special
pair
that electron is ultimately transferred
away
coming down here to cytochrome bf
okay so this moves from a
higher to a lower standard reduction
potential that's favorable so this
should go here through the fee of
fighting
qa
qb etc through a q-like cycle
to get to cytochrome bf and pump a
proton
that would then transfer to plasto
cyanine that would then transfer
ultimately
to photosystem one
okay so there's photosystem one which
also
can absorb a
photon excite
that electron which can be rapidly
transferred away but this time rather
than water being the electron donor
it's the electron transfer from
plastocyanin that resolves the charge
separation
on the special pair as you excite and
transfer
the electron out out ultimately
coming here to ferridoxin
which is at the right standard reduction
potential
to reduce nadp plus to nadph
okay and so this here also would come
through
quinones a0 a1 is what those quinones
are called
in photosystem one that's not important
it's exactly the same thing as what we
described before
and ultimately this is drawing out
basically what happens in the
chloroplast how photosystem 2 and
photosystem 1
fit in with electron transfer in terms
of moving across standard reduction
potentials
now what's cool is that photosystem
one rather than transferring the
electrons
to make nadph also can instead
transfer electrons as an alternative
back to cytochrome bf
well it comes back into cytochrome bf
you can see that basically this now
creates
a loop where you have favorable electron
transfer here
excite favorable electron transfer
excite favorable electron transfer
in essence this here will then pump
a proton by basically transferring
the electron back allowing you to run
this middle part
between photosystem one cytochrome bf
and plastocyanin
create delta psi delta ph at cytochrome
bf
and that allows you to make atp without
generating
nadph or make a battery delta psi delta
ph
do whatever work without generating
ph that's also shown here
on this slide drawn out in a way that
may be slightly neater than what i drew
out
over there but effectively illustrates
the same thing and it's
cool that there's this flexibility to
run
photosynthesis in a way that you can net
generate nadph
but you can also generate just delta psi
delta ph
allowing the plant to meet its energetic
needs
because delta psi delta ph can keep atp
adp ratio high when the lights are on
and then that way the plant has all the
energy it needs to
fight entropy and be alive as a cell
whereas it can also
tune it then to generate the nadph it
needs to make reduced carbon
that it can then store for later all
right
now to make the reduced carbon that can
be stored for later
ultimately now we have to basically
take co2 and turn it into carbohydrate
turn it into glucose
all right this co2
into carbohydrate turning it into
glucose that
hexose sugar that the plant can then
pack away with alpha 1 4 linkages
as starch to burn later when the lights
are off
um requires reduction that reduction
electrons have to come from somewhere
well ultimately they can come from water
via nadph and those are
the dark reactions of photosynthesis
and so let's discuss those next and so
the dark reactions really
are co2 plus
nad ph going to
carbohydrate plus
um nad
p plus these are reactions that can
happen
either in the dark or the light they're
unique to photosynthetic organisms
that's who can
um uh net carry out this reaction
fixing carbon as glucose as reduced
carbon and glucose
these reactions these dark reactions are
going to occur
here in the stroma of the chloroplast
and why is that useful well because this
is where the nadph
and the atp that's going to be required
for these
dark reactions to take place should be
clear to you
nadph is the electron donor but you also
need additional energy input
because this is effectively reversing
glucose oxidation that releases energy
need
energy input and so you're going to see
you also need
atp to adp conversion by happening
in the stroma you have the place where
the nadph and atp
is being produced as products of the
light reaction
okay so these dark reactions of
photosynthesis were discovered
in the 1950s by a gentleman by the name
of melvin
calvin as a result
sometimes the dark reactions are
referred to
as the calvin cycle
to honor him as the discoverer and
basically
the experiment that calvin did is he
took
carbon dioxide that was labeled with
radioactive carbon
so c14 carbon dioxide he basically
fed it to a photosynthetic algae
and found that the first compound that
incorporated
the radioactive co2 was a three carbon
compound
and that three carbon compound was three
phosphoglycerate
okay good old 3pg from glycolysis
and so he found that you could get these
reactions of
co2 going into 3-phosphoglycerate as the
first
thing to incorporate the radioactive
carbon that worked in the light or the
dark and that's where the term
dark reactions came from now it should
be
hopefully clear to you that if i can
generate 3-phosphoglycerate you now know
how to make glucose because now you can
go back and look at your notes from the
gluconeogenesis lecture
and if you had a source of
3-phosphoglycerate you can just run it
through the reactions of gluconeogenesis
and ultimately make glucose
all right turns out that the way this
happens in total is
the so-called calvin cycle really
happens in
three phases all right so the first
phase
is called fixation and so
what is fixation that's basically
kelvin's experiment
it's using co2
to generate 3-phosphoglycerate
all right the second phase
is referred to as reduction so what's
reduction well that's
basically gluconeogenesis so it's using
three phosphoglycerate and turning it
into
glucose all right gluconeogenesis we're
reducing carbon
this is the step of course you need
electrons from somewhere they're going
to come from nadph
you need nadph for that you'll also need
atp
and then the last step is called
regeneration and what you will see
is that the calvin cycle is a cycle that
is you're going to have to have an entry
point
and an exit point and just like we
talked about for the tca cycle if we
feed
two carbon acetyl coa units into the tca
cycle we have to have an acceptor
oxaloacetate in order to run the cycle
and if we pull anything out of the cycle
we need another way to add carbon back
to the cycle
and so regeneration is really
anaplerosis
for the cycle that is you need to
generate the acceptor
that you can keep running this as a
cycle
as a general overview it works as
follows and so it turns out
that the cycle works
with this molecule
as i guess
we're going to draw an analogy to the
tca cycle
where oxaloacetate was the initial
acceptor this is the analogous molecule
to that this is a molecule it's a
five carbon sugar so it's a pentose
phosphorylates a
pentose and a ketose phosphorylated on
the one
and the five position so this is
ribulose
one five bis phosphate
which i will abbreviate
r15p all right
so ribulose one five bisphosphate
will pick up a co2 molecule and it will
make
two
three phosphoglycerate molecules so five
carbons plus one carbon equals six
carbons
break them in half two three
phosphoglycerate molecules
all right once you have that three
phosphoglycerate
i can now use atp
to phosphorylate that three
phosphoglycerate
that'll give me one three
bisphosphoglycerate okay
i can now run the photosynthetic
version of the gap dh reaction which is
exactly the reaction that you saw in
glycolysis except now we're going to use
nadph
rather than nadh as we described for
glycolysis and gluconeogenesis all right
and so that's going to give me
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate can use trios
phosphate isomerase to make
dihydroxyacetone phosphate
i can run the aldolase reaction to make
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate can release a
phosphate
from fructose 1 6 bisphosphate now i
have
fructose 6-phosphate i can isomerize
fructose 6-phosphate to glucose
6-phosphate
and of course if i take the phosphate
off that's glucose
or more importantly what would the plant
do it would then
do a mutate reaction to make glucose one
phosphate and
pack that away in starch much like we
discussed
for putting glucose into glycogen and
then get that
glucose back out as glucose one
phosphate glucose 6-phosphate and send
it to glycolysis
to be oxidized to get energy okay
this is great but you can see that this
is not going to work
unless i can regenerate a source of
ribulose
1 5 bisphosphate turns out
we can do that from fructose 6 phosphate
obviously
atp is going to be required here too
because there's only one phosphate
here you need two phosphates for the the
ribulose
um one five bisphosphate so more atp
is needed
and ultimately that
in a non-stoichiometric way is how the
cycle works
and so if we break this up then
into the different phases
this phase up here would be
fixation this phase down here
is reduction
in this phase over here is regeneration
okay and that's basically the
calvin cycle all right let's go through
these now one at a time let's first talk
about
fixation
fixation is catalyzed by an enzyme
called
rubisco which stands for
ribulose 1-5 bisphosphate
carboxylase
oxygenase
okay so rubisco if you want a bit of
trivia is the most abundant enzyme on
earth
it's about 50 percent of the protein and
chloroplasts
it's a incredibly inefficient enzyme it
has a turnover number of about three per
second
and that's why it's so abundant because
it's a crappy enzyme and so therefore it
needs to have a lot of it around in
order to work
it evolved in a pre-oxygen atmosphere
and now of course there's lots of oxygen
in the atmosphere
and co2 and oxygen will both compete to
react with the enzyme
and it turns out that that's a issue for
photosynthesis
and it's a big deal for agriculture
now the way rubisco works is that
there's a
lysine in the active site
of the enzyme and that lysine is
covalently bound to a co2 molecule
and that co2 molecule covalently bound
to the lysine is not involved in the
reaction but basically if you don't have
enough co2 around to
carboxylate the lysine now you can't
carry out the reaction it's one way
to sort of ensure that there's enough
co2 that this will work
but effectively what that co2 does is
coordinates a magnesium atom
that ultimately coordinates
and positions the ribulose
one five bisphosphate
within the active site
of the enzyme
all right so here's ribulose one five
bisphosphate
bound into the active site of of
rubisco i'll show you quickly how the
rubisco reaction
works and so if we
take the enol or the keto form
of ribulose one five bisphosphate and
re-draw it in the active site
as the keto form
okay so it's
that will react with co2
do
add water
okay
and then ultimately what we are left
with from the top half of the molecule
we get this
one three phosphoglycerate molecule
and on the bottom part also get a
three phosphoglycerate molecules so two
three phosphoglycerates generated so
ultimately what's happening is we're
adding a co2
basically between the um two
and three carbon of ribulose one five
bisphosphate
breaking the molecule in half to get two
three phosphoglycerate molecules just to
quickly show you what happens if at
this step if you instead replace this
with oxygen okay so instead
have oxygen add there instead
well now you end up with this situation
okay so now you have that instead now
when
water gets added
you end up generating from
the bottom half of the molecule
of course a
3-phosphoglycerate so that's not a
problem
but from the top half of the molecule
rather than generating a three
phosphoglycerate now you have this
two carbon unit
which is called phosphoglycolate
and it turns out that phosphoglycolate
is not a good thing for the plant to
have
you basically started with five carbon
ribulose one five bisphosphate
and you end up with three
phosphoglycerate
and a two phosphoglycolate
no carbon is added there and now the
plant
has to deal with the phosphoglycolate so
it has to regenerate the ribulose one
five bisphosphate
so naturally if you're going to take may
rebuild that five carbon molecule
that's going to require energy input
okay and you haven't fixed a co2
so in the end what's required is
actually
more atp and more nadph to solve
the phosphoglycolate problem with no net
gain
for the plant and so as a result
oxygen competing with carbon dioxide
is a big deal for plants by the way
dealing with phosphoglycolate which of
course plants have a way to do
is a process called photorespiration
photorespiration
requires all this atp and nadph so it
requires all this extra light energy
from the plant that's
really not being used for any good
purpose
um for the plant itself
now the process i described is
the standard photosynthesis process and
it's what happens in so-called
c3 plants called c3 because a three
carbon intermediate
is made it turns out that there is also
a class of plants called c4 plants
that basically use a four carbon
intermediate they do the same thing
three plants do but they basically have
a system
that basically uses some extra
atp and nadph in order to generate
um a shuttle to
concentrate co2 to run the rubisco
reaction that i just showed
and so that is shown here on this slide
and so this is what happens in c4 plants
and so effectively you fix a co2
using um basically making oxaloacetate
so that's the four carbon unit
you run an nadph driven version of the
malate dehydrogenase reaction to
ultimately generate malate
and then turn that malate back into
pyruvate releasing co2
back over here into the different parts
use a pepsi k-like reaction
send it to the um the chloroplast where
you then regenerate co2 for the rubisco
enzyme
and you send that pyruvate back out as a
way to run a cycle
um that basically concentrates the co2
so this requires extra atp
requires extra nadph
but in the end it saves the plant the
trouble of having to deal with this
fossil glycolate
not surprisingly this has evolved in
places with high light so
tropical plants are more likely to be c4
plants because they have more light
around more atp and nadph anyway
that allows them to compete with each
other
and concentrate co2 in a way that allows
them to run
the rubisco reaction
all right reduction the next phase up
here there's actually not a lot
to say this is basically just
gluconeogenesis
using nadph
and of course you can use it to generate
glucose but
plants would rather generate glucose one
phosphate and store it
as starch or something else some storage
sugar for the plant
itself all right now what should be
clear to you is that
well we started with a five carbon unit
and we added a one carbon unit
and in the end if we're going to net
generate a
glucose
we're going to have to run that cycle
six times
right because we need a five carbon unit
to come out the end
as well as a six build a six carbon unit
just from co2 and so
regeneration is really how do we go from
net six co2
to one glucose molecule that is
how can we combine that reduction step
while also regenerating ribulose
one five bisphosphate to keep running
this
as a cycle and so in essence what we
need is we need to take
six five carbon units
okay so that's a total of
30 carbons all right
and we're going to have 6x co2 molecules
there's another six carbons all right
so that's a total of 36
carbons in and then we're gonna have to
allocate those carbons
to regenerate six five carbon units
so the 30 carbons
we need it for the cycle as well as
one glucose
okay the remaining six carbons that
pexos
how this happens is confusing i'm sorry
i didn't invent this
nature invented this but it's
essentially
accomplished via a series of two carbon
and three carbon swaps
and why it's two carbon and three carbon
swaps and not
i don't know why don't did nature just
come up with something more
straightforward
is well grounded in the chemistry of how
these reactions happen we'll describe
the chemistry of the
swapping reactions in great detail next
time
you'll see that the swaps occur between
aldoses and ketosis
and so there's actually good
evolutionary
reasons you'll see that those reactions
will be analogous to things that we've
seen before
and effectively nature rather than
making it easy for you to memorize
things
came up with a way that actually fit
what um
happens that enables carbon
rearrangement in a way that will make
this pathway work and so
before i go into the details of
exactly how this happens i just want to
lay out for you
at a very very high level
how those swaps can work to accomplish
this goal
all right so basically if we're going to
start
with five carbons
and we're going to add co2
what's that going to generate well we're
going to generate by the rubisco
reaction
three carbon units all right so if i
start with six of these
and six of these i can generate
12 three carbon units
all right now i can take
of those 12 three carbon units and
obviously
combine them via the reduction reactions
gluconeogenesis
ways to generate six carbon units and
that ultimately
is going to be the glucose that i get
out
all right so it turns out if i do this
reaction five times so that's
ten three carbon units all right but if
i take some of
so that means i'm going to get in the
end five
six carbon units well if i use
two of those units
and i do a swap with the remaining two
of these three carbon units that is i
transfer two carbons from
here to there what am i gonna get well
if i
that means two carbons six minus two is
i get a four carbon unit three plus two
is a five carbon unit
that's good all right that's what i'm
trying to get so i took two there
two here so that stoichiometry adds up
here i had 12 of these made
five plus five plus two equals ten five
of them down here
to these guys two of them with this swap
with the three carbon units
now i end up getting two of the six
five carbon units that i need to make
well now i'm left here with two
four carbon units i still here i took
one
away here two away there five minus two
minus one is two left
so i still have two two carbon units
here to go
so i can use my remaining two carbon
units
to react with those four carbon units if
i now move three carbons from here to
there
all right six minus three
is three four plus three is seven
now i generate a seven carbon unit two
of these
two of these all right now if i take two
carbons from my seven carbon unit give
it to the three carbon unit
what do i have well now i have i've made
two different five carbon units
so two plus two plus two equals six five
carbon units
back all right so it can
work i will end today
by drawing out the details of how it
works and then i will redraw them next
time and we'll go through in great
detail
how it works all right so
let's start here with our ribulose one
five
bisphosphate
carry out the rubisco reaction i get two
3pg molecules i can run
those 3pg molecules using atp
and nad ph ultimately
to generate
some
three phosphoglycerate molecules
i can isomerize
i'm sorry glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
molecules i can isomerize those to
also generate dihydroxyacetone
phosphate molecules
okay
and of course this is
what i need to generate fbp and
ultimately
generate
fructose 6-phosphate
and that fructose 6-phosphate of course
can be used to generate
glucose and i'm not going to draw the
steps for it
okay all stuff you know rubisco
reaction and then gluconeogenesis
ultimately to get
glucose okay now here's where it gets
interesting so now let's use
our fructose 6-phosphate
and our glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
all right so
i can generate a five carbon
sugar
called
called xyulose
5-phosphate that's a 5-carbon sugar
if i use an epimerase
and phosphorylate it with atp
now i can regenerate a ribulose
five bisphosphate
i've also now will generate
this four carbon sugar
called erythros
4-phosphate okay and i can take
this erythrose 4-phosphate
swap three carbons which will give me
this seven
carbon sugar called
acetohepulose
seven phosphate
okay as well as a
three carbon
glyceraldehyde three phosphate now i can
swap
two carbons again and that gives me
a
ribose
5-phosphate and another
so this is ribose
5-phosphate and another
xylose 5-phosphate
so x5p cellulose 5-phosphate
i can now do exactly the same thing i
did before
with the xylose 5-phosphate where i do
an epimerase reaction
and phosphorylate it so pemerase
from the ribose 5-phosphate i can do an
isomerase reaction
and phosphorylate it and in the end
i now generate five carbon
ribulose one five bisphosphates
so if i start with six ribulose one five
bisphosphates and six co2 molecules
what do i end up with well now i end up
with
12 glyceraldehyde 3-phosphates
if i allocate two of them here five of
them here
and five of them here that allows me to
generate
five fructose six phosphate molecules
if i allocate two of them there pull one
of them out
as glucose and the remaining two here
i get two of these and two of these
i can carry this through two of these
and two of those there's two of these
two of those two these and two of those
so i end up with two here
two here that's two four six five carbon
units
ending up as ribulose one five
bisphosphate
and so i can feed six co2s in
get a glucose out and net regenerate
six ribulose one five bisphosphates
all at the cost of six atps there
another 12 atps here to do the
um gluconeogenesis reactions
and another six um i'm sorry 12
nadphs to generate all of these three
carbon units
and in the end pull out one glucose
molecule
we'll start with this i know it's very
confusing i will redraw that out i'll go
through it again
at the start of the next lecture thank
you